now UK intelligence institutions leading
a campaign to warn British universities
of foreign spy activity in particular
they warn that Chinese students could be
undercover agents hostile state actors
are targeting UK universities to steal
personal data research data and
intellectual property and this could be
used for their own military commercial
and authoritarian interests the
universities have been given advice on
how to minimize the threat and protect
key research from hostile foreign actors
according to government data the number
of Chinese students at UK universities
has doubled in the last 10 years and at
the same time foreign students do
account for almost 20 percent of British
universities income we our students in
the UK what they thought about the idea
that there could be spies sitting in on
their lectures I fear so if they're
making a claim they need some sort of
like actual data to back up I just don't
think it's happening though unlikely I
don't think there's a huge amount again
I think there are better areas to target
by understructure if you were to do it
I'd be quite surprised actually because
UCL's meant to be an institution where
students come together and you know
share ideas and discuss things having
Chinese spies like in the university
would you know kind of inhibit that and
you know of course students the field
you know the needs to be careful about
what they're saying and they can't
really share ideas and you know be open
about what they think does it make my
first ability would it my surprise
that's what was happening Hong Kong and
it's going to spread to if this is a
real concern then there could be like a
vetting process before like any of us
apply to University could check our like
background our history just to like you
know how they're doing jobs to like
their system check just to make sure
we're on like some database for the
government working for them so very
probably trying to do the same probably
not as effectively
so fair game well UK government
spokesperson did confirm to RT that
security agencies are indeed working
with universities to protect them from
spying although without specifying China
as a particular threat political
scientist Joseph Cheng no fears that the
campaign could actually make it harder
for genuine Chinese academics to carry
out their research abroad these strong
suspicions against China may well
constitute a serious obstacle to normal
academic exchanges one understands that
today the United States and some Western
countries are now spending tremendous
efforts in screening these exchange
programs and it becomes much more
difficult for Chinese academics for
Chinese postgraduate students to engage
in exchange programs to engage in
studies in Western countries the general
suspicions now concentrating on China
may well spread to other countries like
Russia and certain countries considered
unfriendly towards the United States and
other Western countries
you